Lilliana runs a cake decorating business
for which 10% of her orders come over
the telephone
let's see B the number of cake orders
Liliana receives in a month until she
first gets an order over the telephone
assumed a method of placing each cake
order is independent so see if we assume
a few things as a classic geometric
random variable what tells us that well
a giveaway is that we're gonna keep
doing these independent trials where the
probability of success is constant
there's a clear success a telephone
order in this case is a success the
probability is 10% of it happening and
we're gonna keep doing it until we get a
success so classic geometric random
variable now they asked us find the
probability the probability that it
takes fewer than five orders for Liliana
to get her first telephone order of the
month so it's really the probability
that C is less than five so like always
pause this video and have a go at it and
even if you struggle with it that's even
that's that's better your brain will be
more primed for the actual solution that
we can go through together all right so
I'm assuming you've had a go at it so
there's a couple of ways to approach it
you could say well look this is just
going to be the probability that C is
equal to 1 plus the probability that C
is equal to 2 plus the probability that
C is equal to 3 plus the probability
that C is equal to 4 and we can
calculate it this way what is the
probability that C equals 1 well so
probability that her very first order is
a telephone order and so we'll have 0.1
what's the probability at C equals 2
well sir probability that her first
order is not a telephone order so it's 1
minus 10% there's a 90% chance it's not
a telephone order and that her second
order is a telephone order what about
the probability C equals 3 well her
first two orders would not be telephone
orders and her third order would be 1
and then C equals 4 well heard first
three orders would not be telephone
orders and her fourth one would and we
could get a calculator maybe and add all
of these things up
and we would actually get the answer but
you probably wonder well this is kind of
hairy to type into a calculator maybe
there is an easier way to tackle this
and indeed there is so think about it
the probability that C is less than 5
that's the same thing as 1 minus the
probability that we don't have a
telephone order in the first for one
minus the probability that no telephone
order in first 4 orders so what's this
well because this is just saying we you
know what's the problem we do have an
order in the first four so it's the same
thing as 1 minus the probability that we
don't have an order in the first 4 and
this is pretty straightforward to
calculate so this is going to be equal
to 1 minus and let me do this in another
color so we know what I'm referring to
so what's the probability that we have
no telephone orders in the first four
orders well the probability on a given
order that you don't have a telephone
order is 0.9 and then if that has to be
true for the first four well it's going
to be 0.9 times 0.9 times 0.9 times 0.9
or 0.9 to the fourth power so this is a
lot easier to calculate so let's do that
let's get a calculator out all right so
let me just take point nine to the
fourth power is equal to and then let me
subtract that from one so let me make
that a negative and then let me add one
to it and we get there you go zero point
three four three nine so this is equal
to zero point three four three nine and
we're done
that's the probability that takes fewer
than five orders for her to get her
first telephone order of the month